wait for the stream
right i'll declare this uh extraordinary
performance policy and partnerships
committee meeting open
uh on zun councillor crackit and an
apology from councillor abbott also
departures from um reverend cook and mrs
coote
that accounts for everybody i think
yes it does
somebody move the apologies accepted
councillor scouts second did kelsey
evanson put that all in favor
against carried uh we have a major late
item um and mrs hadley can i throw to
you in the first instance to sorry steve
i beg your pardon
to to give us uh an outline of what it
is
why it's here and then we can decide
what we do
uh thank you mr chair councillors your
worship
um the team at splash palace
late last week received correspondence
from a school
advising that with some of the
changes to the
education outside the classroom
messaging that had gone through the
ministry of education and through the
school community
uh indicating that
children involved in education outside
the classroom
for ages over 12 years and three months
were exempt from
the
mandatory vaccination
passport requirements
and that obviously prompted our our team
to raise the question with me and then
we've raised it uh with andrew and
claire as to
uh would that change our position and um
claire then saw or the chief executive
sorry sought
to seek some advice from local
government new zealand
sorry the local government central
government covert unit
and
look at it be fair to say it's not clear
in terms of
whether or not we should change and so
we're bringing this conversation to you
today
and we'll provide some advice in terms
of what it means for our two facilities
that would most likely hold education
outside the classroom which would be
splash palace in the library
the the main
[Music]
statement from the email reads councils
can choose to suspend the use of the
vaccine passes free atc for children 12
years three months and up or the largest
school groups where event gatherings
settings cannot be complied with
to do so you will need to ensure that
you are able to manage eitc participants
in a defined space
and that terminology-defined space is
critical for us because within splash
palace we only have one we have two
defined spaces
it's the entire pool hall and it's the
small learn to swim facility
to the side in the library the library
is one defined space
and that's on the basis that is uh is
set out in the health order
that sits that are defined space or as a
single space
that is
does not share the airflow with another
space
and as a result we've got a library
which has a commonly shared airspace
airflow and so it's it's just one and so
in order to fit eotc and to follow this
mandate we would shut it to everyone
else
in splash palace
we have a a separate facility in the
lunar swim pool but common areas
uh in the reception and the changing
room
which essentially makes it
theoretically possible but practically
impossible so we wanted to bring this
advice to you today
to get your guidance on
do we want to adjust our
mandatory vaccination passport
requirement and on
the structure of the facilities
we don't actually think that there is a
driver there that would warrant that but
that's
from what we've looked at the advice
and
through you chair for the chief
executive if i've missed anything please
feel free to and
thank you mr giblin okay first of all
procedurally an error on my part i did
not move that we receive this and deal
with it as a major late item i will do
so if there's a sector councillor
podenta thank you or put that all in
favor
against
kerry
so to to pricing clarified then steve
the
minister made a a statement in the media
during a preset on on friday
which
has been difficult to to verify and i i
guess one of the issues that's
that's raised is is around equity
but it's been raised with us
throughout the entire vaccination
passport process
however
the advice that you've provided this
afternoon indicates that there are
complications around
airspace if it was
education outside of the classroom
activities specifically they need their
own
and we can't provide that at the library
and we can't
provide that at splash palace because of
the combined reception and changing
facilities is that correct
that that's correct um
and if i might add to
the lunar swim pool is designed for
people who are quite a lot younger
and
the age category we're talking about is
for children over 12 years and three
months and that facility
probably isn't appropriate for the the
stage of development around winter swim
so
the the issue is i guess in the public
side further complicated by the fact
that we've seen
changes
in this past week around miq for for
both australian visitors and firstly in
the shortening of the time
for those that landed on the first day
suddenly they found instead of three
days it was two days
and for those arriving
from the rest of the world from from
later in the week so there is that sense
that some of some of the
covert response requirements
not mandates
are shifting as the omicron variant
reaches a higher saturation level
today's figure by the way 20 000 new
cases
it's always been the government's
intention from what they've indicated
bearing in mind it has been confusing
from time to time that they were going
to review
the mandate issue
if i've understood this correctly
after
the expected peak
which is due around
mid-march and
based on the initial projections and and
current figures that seems to be
seems to be the case
so the question is does the committee uh
wish to proceed with a review now or is
it going to be better for us to indicate
that
we are prepared to look at things again
post the peak when there is a change in
status that comes from central
government i think that's the issue that
we're faced with councillor claire
yeah two or three things on that
through your chair um
the advice we got from the ministry
health at the southern
leadership group recently was that while
the peak may very well be in
mid to early march uh for most of the
country we were a little bit of a
lag behind that
so they were suggesting that
it may be well into april before we see
the spike here you can see that with the
national trends but the modeling has
been very careful
um so we may wish to wait for that
given that when the government eases the
pedal off in auckland and waikato and
some of those other areas it may not
quite be right for us so that's one
consideration
i guess the other consideration is i
mean i've done about other councils but
i've had quite a bit of feedback from
people that are very opposed to not
being able to swim at the pool because
they don't have a mandate not the
library but this definitely the pool
and we've held a fairly consistent line
with that
you've got your passport you haven't the
moment we start inching that out for
some
education type sectors because it's more
convenient for them to have the kids
there than to have to try and manage
them not being there for the ones that
don't
have the vaccines i think we open up a
pandora's box so i think we'll have more
opposition from communities who say well
i'm not going to go to the pool now
because you're opening it up to the
non-vex i think we should just wait a
little while
thank you
councillor scout yeah through youtube
thank you just supporting steve and the
comments he's made just being involved
in another venue
unfortunately the announcement on friday
from the minister and then supported by
the good doctor
um has just caused huge confusion
um with without a shadow of a doubt so
with an over the weekend from from our
venue um staff have been abused
regarding that those comments um the
phone has been very um active personally
it's been very active to me
um our venue was tagged last evening
um as a result of that comment that was
made
in the sense so that the community are
incensed
some of the community are in sense i
should say to each here so unfortunately
the misinformation or the information
that was given out at best was confusing
i'll use another word but anyway
it's just unfortunate exceptionally
unfortunate because now we have
stirred up emotion again once again
through confusing information
steve is absolutely correct in the sense
of defined space is the key
it is defined space is the key in
everything we read
and the pool the library stadium south
and
venues and so on and so far it's just
impossible to actually in practicality
sense
and practicality to operate it's simple
but it's causing mayhem in the sense of
the wider community
so just a question of clarification then
counselor skill in the example of the
stadium
even though you're able to have
different parts of the stadium isolated
off it's still that common entry point
that provides the issue correct thank
you councillor sopa
thanks mr chair i just want to i just
want to support all the previous
speakers and steve and what they've said
um and i i do just want to add the some
of the some of the um
recent um
stuff you referred to
i would just like to point out that that
is the miq facilities etcetera that is
um presuming that the
incoming people are vaccinated so we are
looking at quite a different scenario
here
we are still talking are we not steve
about a request that unvaccinated
participants in education outside the
classroom would be allowed into our
facilities and we are not at the point
where i would be prepared to change what
we have decided on that basis it may be
something that we can re-look at well it
will be something that we re-look at
once the peak is over but this is not
the time
and there is just no
logical reason why we would make that
change now
thank you uh welcome mrs coote
andrew are you able to provide a little
extra
light on the scenario
i just want to make sure that
the whole issue is confusing and the
problem that continually arises and it
arose when council first considered this
matter this you had a range of
overlaying pieces of legislation that
impact this decision
and i think the response that
claire got from local government doesn't
really
assist you in separating those two
different issues
the key point that i think is not fully
understood or appreciated
is the final sentence
which basically says the decision by
council to mandate vaccine passes at
these venues was not sorry to require
vaccine passports was never mandated
so that's a decision that council has
made
the eotc requirements only apply when
you're talking about mandated spaces
um
and it's as simple as that so that's
council skelt's problem he has a
mandated space if he wants to operate
the venue over certain numbers
he's caught by the mandate council
facilities again subject to the number
limits while we're in red never required
a vaccine passport
so you could have
education occurring there without
complying with the
education requirements
it just has to meet whatever council's
requirements for that space are
so by by putting those two things
together as confused at which drives
council staff down the define space
question which is really not the issue
of course you only have the defined
space problem if you're operating on the
eotc rules which council doesn't have to
we've said we've got a mandate
requirement
but we don't that doesn't automatically
bring the education rules in i mean i
know it's complicated but can everyone
understand these two different questions
here so the difference being
the space that ielts stadium southland
is because it takes a far greater number
of people is different to
the likes of the library and splash
palace where
council policy
has required
the the provision of a vaccination
discussion when this this was first
raised council could always operate
these facilities without a mandate
without a vaccine passport sorry
um
it was council's election to impose the
vaccine passport
so if we if we let people without a
vaccine passport into those facilities
we wouldn't necessarily have the defined
space question to deal with
because that's not part of
our our ability to let them in if that
makes sense
but of course the sports facilities
different facilities have
requirements that are
are imposed as soon as they elect to
operate
that then
drives them down a different path but
it's just really confusing and i
appreciate it's difficult for everyone
to understand but it is important
because
it's this it's the mixed messaging out
of the government we're loosing up we're
not losing anywhere but they're not
giving anyone the clarity to be able to
make the decision but at the moment
the schools can't go there because they
don't have a vaccine passport if you
said we're going to let schools or
certain school children go without a
vaccine passport that would just be a
decision that council made it wouldn't
have to have the defined space overlay
but the schools would still need to be
able to comply with their side they'd
have to have a teacher that's vaccinated
all those other bits from their side
would still be required to apply but not
necessarily the venue requirements
thanks andrew that did help
mostly councillor clark
just as a reflection on that and what
leslie was um
advising earlier or commenting on
earlier
um when you look at the stats for
omnichrome at the moment there's a
disproportionate amount of teenagers in
the hospital administration
and the ministry has said it's because
not because they're not vaccinated it's
because they're more mobile
they tend to you know you see it in the
castle street type parties recently and
other things like that
so given that increased risk in the 12
years plus group
and given that we at the pool service
people who are maybe compromised
elderly people that have hip and other
issues that may want to do aqua jogging
or mild levels of swimming
i think we need to balance those two out
and not lose sight of the people that
are there that will not appreciate
reopening the doors on that until we
know the spike's gone and the risk
minimises down
councillor pottinger
look i go back to december 7th when
elected members in this room
voted unanimously except for
myself and council ludlow
on mandating both venues now
there were no community cases in sight i
don't think even in the south island yet
um to me there seemed to be a sense of
extreme paranoia and leap into the most
extreme
um
mandate policy when other councils
around the
south island had
a look and see
approach where they
would see how many community cases they
were and then act from that i guess
we've missed our chance um i would i
would like to now revert
the policies and open up both the
library and the pool i mean i'd love to
see how omicron survives in a high
chlorine
environment
that's just my own intrigue but
yeah look i think we've we've done our
dash we had our opportunity we did not
consider all practical options
and as andrew has commentated we
it really is in our hands and i still
remember a number of the elected members
in this room
saying we need to show leadership well
i don't call that leadership when that
decision was made now is an opportunity
to actually show the leadership but i
still don't see it coming
councillor arnold uh yeah i'd just like
to watch my support for what counselor
partner was just saying
oh in fact um they've never been
comfortable with it and um from what
we're hearing of the omicron thing i
think it's um
it's a lot milder that the borders are
basically opening up to people who are
sure they vaccinate or they test
negative
i believe coming into the country
um it's kind of we're opening to the
world very very shortly government's
given mixed messages i believe that
we should be doing the same thing
discount sponsors council bonds are
suggesting that's uh
opening up facilities to all children
or people
library and pool
that's my view
so and we can change that i believe
council is able to review its policy at
any stage your worship
yes
um
the
issue
i'm wrestling with is how we deal with
the march that's coming in the morning
um
it's
i i volunteered as did
um councillor clark
and
we
were told that last time we met a group
of their leaders
i think it went for two and a half hours
the meeting
and the government was saying you
shouldn't meet
these people
and i think it's
if we want to keep sort of civil unrest
to a minimum standard
from my experience the
it's better to downplay it as much as
possible
and
i see the other councils that put up
showers for that
and
i think that softly approach is a good
one
thank you worship now the wellington
council didn't bring in the showers the
um the freedom protesters did
i think tomorrow to put it into a
context is simply about receiving a
petition
council is anybody else counselor sopa
thanks mr chia i just wanted to say
from my point of view we have the same
vulnerable populations
as we had when we made this decision
i see no reason why we should not
continue with this course's cautious
approach at this time
when we have reached the peak in this
region
that would be a sensible time for
council to re-look at this matter but at
the moment from my point of view
the same vulnerable populations are
there as were there when we took the
decision
they provided very valid reasons why we
took the decision we did
my view on that has not changed at all
at this time
uh councillor scott thank you for your
chair and i can only echo council of
cyprus sentiments i can't come to grips
with either council partners or
counselors and or summation of
because medically if you just read
simply the medical
data around
the findings and the population and
where it's moving to it's quite simple
without me sounding arrogant
and and cancer soap is correct we need
to get to the peak
before we go anywhere and do anything
so i'm just dumbfounded to be honest um
that we would even be considering this
we have not we have an obligation to our
community and in particular our
vulnerable community and our young folk
and if you look at the stats it's clear
it's very
very clear
so i
yeah councillors you've received the
verbal report and we're now looking for
a decision so
what we need is a recommendation on the
table
councillor
clark
um
so would it be helpful for somebody to
put a motion that we maintain the status
quo that we've got at the moment
until a certain time frame and then
review it again
that or not are our options i see yep
and let people vote according well i'll
move a motion that we maintain the
current passport system for library
splash palace and this chamber
um
and and through until the mid middle of
april
and reconsider it then
second second
we give some certainty for about just
for about six months point of point of
order
um i'm just wondering looking at the
late the late item um
i thought this was a report to be
received and uh if any action further
action was to be quiet then a further
staff report would come back with
details and options not a not a kangaroo
court type
thanks mrs hadley
mr chair i wonder if the way forward
would be for if councillor clark was so
prepared
would be to break that motion into two
parts the first being that there be no
change in stance
and the second being a request for a
report
to the meeting to be held on tuesday the
12th of april
noting that school holidays would start
on friday the 15th of april
and so that may be a useful time frame
in which to reconsider the matter with
an officer's report attached
happy to support that chair and and the
rationale for that is i get quite a bit
of feedback from what you'd loosely call
the antivex group to say well we don't
agree with what you've done but when are
you going to review it is it now
relevant or not and i think that
satisfies that so motion in two parts i
think i might have been recorded as the
second of the original motion and i
would also agree
to split into those two parts
okay
is anybody clear on the motions that the
current stance is maintained and that
uh a paper comes back and is reviewed at
our meeting on april 12th
any further questions or comments
if not i'll put the two motions all
those in favor
against
no
carry thank you
that was the only item that we had for
this
extraordinary meeting so i'll close it
and we will have a
workshop underway very shortly that will
end our stream thank you very much
you